sometimes Donald Trump is so
disconnected from reality that his
hallucinations go all the way around the
universe and on the way back
accidentally collide with reality from
the other direction we may be faced with
exactly that scenario in Sunday night's
second debate by all accounts Trump
thinks he won the first debate and won
it handily he was still relitigated come
on Twitter nearly five full days after
he walked off the stage at Hofstra still
citing the same meaningless American
Idol style online votes still blaming
the media spin even though he had gone
into the spin room for the express
purpose of spinning media also by all
accounts those around Trump know he
actually titanic's if they held some
hopes of having merely a minor defeat to
deal with those have been dispensed with
as this week has worn on by widening
real poll numbers especially in
battleground states like Pennsylvania
thus Trump thinks he goes on to the
stage in st. Louis Sunday night needing
to land just one more dramatic historic
punch to the metaphorical gut to finish
Hillary Clinton for good while his
handlers think he goes onto the stage in
st. Louis Sunday night meaning to land a
dramatic historic punch to the
metaphorical guts or Hillary Clinton
will have finished him for good this
means that both the voices around Trump
and the voices in his head are telling
him not to hold back not to look
reasonable not to try to undo the impact
of his self-defense tracin at Hofstra in
other words not to do the only things he
could do to convince that middle swath
of voters that he is not as unlikable
not as unstable not as thin-skinned not
as boastful not as crazy as he appeared
oops if we saw angry Trump in the first
debate I think we can expect very angry
Trump in the second one and we already
have a few hints as to what he's angry
about he dropped one in Mannheim
Pennsylvania last Saturday just as his
tax avoidance story was about to hit the
New York Times website having already
talked about Hillary Clinton's marriage
and her reaction to the women who
threatened it he now moved on to what is
political science fiction even among the
very large and long-established crowd of
people driven crazy by the very
fact that there are Clinton's quote I
don't even think she's loyal to pill you
want to know the truth and really folks
really why should she be right this was
new ground alleging some kind of
infidelity on her part
it became an applause line Trump may use
it at the debate or he may even go
further considering that bizarre high
that he gets when he gets rolling really
gets him high I would need favorable
odds to actually predict this but I
would not be surprised if he decided to
make up specifics about who he thinks
she was disloyal to bill with we got
another hint Tuesday about anger in
Prescott Valley Arizona on the subject
of his tax avoidance Trump simply
refuses to stop digging this one is as
wild and illogical as anything Trump has
yet said but remember he has spent the
week testing the waters to find that one
topic that he thinks will summarily win
him the presidency on Sunday night now
after years of failure she complains
about how I've used tax laws of this
country to my benefit then I asked a
simple question why didn't she ever try
to change those laws so I couldn't use
them it's the old line I told you I'd
shoot why didn't you believe me
but it's elevated to a rationalization
of the one thing that has done the most
damage to Trump's campaign the premise
oversimplification though it may be that
he hasn't paid any taxes since 1995 how
to get out of it make it her fault I
didn't want to write off nine hundred
sixteen million dollars in losses the
laws she didn't change forced me into it
never mind that Clinton didn't get to
the Senate until six years after Trump
pulled whatever he pulled and he still
hasn't denied a word of the New York
Times report nor any of the inferences
drawn from it it's her fault he broke
the moral equivalent of the law not his
fault since he's the law and order
candidate in the last week Trump has
also veered into some borderline
hallucinations and remember he thinks he
is the victim in the Alicia Machado
story that she should have been more
grateful to him and back in Arizona he
had a doozy of a far more serious dream
quotes
we're in a nation divided with race
riots in the street you'll look at
what's going on race riots in the street
sure race riots hey trump emic trump
face you'll keep using those words I do
not think they mean what you think they
mean forecasting Sunday we also have a
few hints on how the moderators Martha
Raddatz and Anderson Cooper might behave
firstly they won't have to behave all
that much this is a town hall format
half the questions will come from the
audience so you know what that means
god help us but as the Washington Post
noted the day after the first debate my
old friend Martha who I worked with in
local news in Boston 32 years ago went
on Good Morning America and she was
astonished the Trump had referenced
never striking first with nuclear
weapons but then finished the same deal
by insisting he would never take any
options off the table she said I think
all of us at the table last night were
saying he said what we had no idea what
he was talking about in the end whether
he wanted first use or whether he didn't
want any first use maybe that next
debate we'll see so that's one of the
questions as to style the post notes the
same day cooper praised Phil Donahue for
his hands-off approach that he used in a
Democratic primary debate in 1992 he
said I think there is a value in
stepping back you don't want it to be
about you you want it to be a discussion
about the two and if one is interrupting
the other that tells the audience
something and people can make up their
own minds about what exactly that means
so we may need to be sending out a
search party for Anderson Cooper on
Sunday night you may have noticed that I
have not mentioned in this forecast what
Hilary Clinton might do and that is
simply because there is nothing for her
to do but to continue to treat Donald
Trump the way she did in the first
debate as a guy who sounds like he just
escaped from somewhere don't overreact
don't get angry don't let him get away
with anything
keep that same smile on your face like
an indulgent parent who caught her
seven-year-old with his hand in the
cookie jar and has the audio recorded on
her phone plus a videotape satellite
imaging and 17 depositions
and it's just waiting for his temper
tantrum to play out one last reminder by
way of preview whatever Trump does
Sunday night remember he thinks he's
winning and needs just one more good one
to clinch it and as much as the
Republican hierarchy tries to disown him
he is the essence of their party in one
respect at least when a crazy-ass
argument of theirs does not work
politicizing terrorism shoving
patriotism down people's throats
rescinding women's rights none of them
ever think hey that didn't work drop it
they just repeat it and they say it
louder
in short Trump is gonna call Hillary a
new name of some kind that he thinks
will disqualify her and it won't it will
disqualify him to paraphrase Boris
badenov from rocky and bullwinkle
I send him package to lady which is
really bomb door gets locked she can't
get out who gets blown up me that's the
closer I'm Keith Olbermann watch this
space